this is a production of Cornell
University
over the last 20 years or so I've been
obviously doing a lot of work on
photoreceptors and the photo trope ins
and I got kind of sidetracked and that's
what I'm going to talk about today
because we discovered that there were
some interesting things going on in
guard cells but for us at least were
quite unexpected perhaps not to others
and so we'll just continue we're going
to be talking about stubborn function
but i thought i'd give a little bit of
early history for example of way back in
1836 charles daubeny at cambridge
university did a very interesting
experiment and i'll show you this
experimental setup in just just a minute
but he showed that blue light was much
better than red light in reducing plants
to lose water and to my knowledge this
is the first actual observation of a
specific effect of blue light on shards
on stomatal function although obviously
he didn't know anything about that at
the time then in 1898 Francis Darwin
invented a little device called a
parameter and first demonstrated that
life increased the rate at which you
could pull air through a leaf again
indicative of some change in the
physical properties of the leaf that
allowed lure of gas movement across it
was long assumed however despite this
experiment by Domini about showing blue
light to be so effective was assumed
that stumble opening was strictly
responding to photosynthesis and after
all we have chloroplasts the guard cells
so why not and it was only much much
much later that ogawa showed that blue
light alone doesn't have much of an
effect in increasing transpiration but
against a red light background in such a
spectacular and you've got a huge
increase in transpiration
and then tiger and field refined the
measurements and demonstrated that it
was highly specific for blue light and
as we know now it's a response mediated
by the photo trumpets well here was da
Bonnie's very ingenious experiment he
was various colored glass and he used
also some solutions that were colored
and Simply Measured he would put
concentrated sulfuric acid which is of
course hygroscopic takes up water and
he'd weigh it and then he would put it
down to rebelled jar and turn the light
on and when he turns when he turns no
light on he got a much bigger increase
in the weight of the cell Surak acid
over time than if he turned the red
light on incidentally he also noticed
something else and that was that red
light was far more effective than blue
in inducing what he described as the
secretion of green matter into the
leaves which of course was that he was
seeing for the first time the
development of of Thoreau field
transformation the protocol
ornithological Oracle I'd and then all
of the phytochrome responses that follow
that to get matura chloroplasts so this
was just a nice piece of work that got
totally lost so this is again the first
report of blue light response guard cell
function then here is Darwin Francis
Darwin spirometer you take a leaf and
then you seal a little suction cup there
and hope to just hook it up to a of
durrette like this and then you measure
the rate at which the liquid drops and
of course if you turn the light on and
the stoma to open the guard cells
separate and the rate at which it drops
increases and then you turn the light
off and it goes back down again a very
elegant very simple demonstration again
which has been pretty much lost more
recently
we identified Photoshop ins and one of
them but one eventually durella it over
the first to identify the second floor
open and then can you see it at all in
shimazaki slab in Japan demonstrated
that both foot one and foe to mediate
light-activated normal opening so now
we've come to the point where we can
actually identify those photoreceptors
involved in the light response first
described by Charles Domini well in the
last three decades or so they've learned
a tremendous amount about stone mental
development the number of different
people working on this and the genes
that are responsible of transcription
factors involved we've also another
totally unrelated in many ways we've
learned a tremendous about the ion pumps
and channels that are involved in
stomatal opening and closing how we
learn know about the specific role of a
bisazza kassadin closing but there's not
a whole lot of work that's been done on
the a possible role of the cytoskeleton
in stomatal function particularly not
microtubules i mean there are some very
nice studies from young so clean in
korea on acting changes with so little
opening and closing and other papers
since then but not particularly so let
me let me now degress slightly because
we got interested in stomach in quite
indirectly things happen to photo
chocolate when you turn the light on and
of course one of the first things to
happen is that you get extensive
phosphorylation second thing we now know
that you get can get binding of a 1433
protein to a particular serine in boat
to highly specific we know that you can
get modern ubiquitination here probably
other places too according to Liscomb
and this is all work that was done by
a long-term postdoc Duncan sang in the
lab so here's photo 12 in structure you
have a serine threonine kinase a classic
sir III cut serine threonine kinase and
then you have two domains of about 100
amino acids which find a slavin which is
the comma 4 and both photo tropin have
this structure when you turn the light
on saturation these are all the
different amino acids that are
phosphorylated the ones in blue were
discovered by the Japanese group the
ones in black were discovered by John
Christy's group and the ones in red or
ones each time you do this you pick up
different ones we've just done another
mass spec experiment and we've picked up
three more that haven't been reported so
I think the number of phosphorylations
that occurs which light saturation
probably is not yet completely
identified okay well one of the things
that aren't true did was yeast
two-hybrid and he found that folk too
was associating with the a1 subunit of a
PB of a protein phosphatase pp2a and
both by east to hybrid and by pull down
so then the question is well is that
phosphatase going to play a role in
actually can children it was the love
domain that was apparently where the
binding was occurring in not the kinase
domain so we hypothesized that blue
light would induce phosphorylation and
with the wild-type enzyme then you can
inactivate and so but this was a way to
deactivate the system after after
photoactivation however we hypothesized
that if you will have an impaired
phosphatase then you should actually at
steady-state increase the amount of the
actress phosphorylated vote too and it
was clear that phosphorylation was
required for her normal function and if
that's the case then we might expect
first motor trophies it might be more
sensitive and stumble aperture at steady
state might be in fact wider and so when
we looked at phototropism sure enough if
we got got rid of folk too I'm sorry I
got rid of thought one so that we're
just eating it folk to behavior in the
absence of the in the impaired activity
of the phosphatase not only did we get a
more rapid phototropic response but we
actually got more curvature more
curvature over time so the that
indicated we then looked at guard cells
here they are closed I won't show you
the quantitation but here's what it
looks like when they're normally open
but in the absence of in the absence of
functioning phosphatase with the mutant
phosphatase none of the guard cells are
far wider open than they are in the
wild-type so in both cases it appears
that the phosphatase is down regulating
the functional molecule well it was
interesting the interaction between
photo/florida to open two effects
phototropism instrumental aperture but
no other folk to a mediated response
that we tested they were all absolutely
the same with or without that mutation
in the phosphatase and furthermore pp2a
this same mutant had no impact
whatsoever when what we looked at was
sort of token one function instead of
photoshop and to function well so our
second brush with guard cells that was
our first or second brush with yard
sales had to do with another of dawn
Shoney's discoveries from yeast
two-hybrid and that is that there's a
14-3 the lambda isoform interacts with
photo acted photo trophy to at a
particular serine
at Syrian 747 and again yeast two-hybrid
and pull down verified that there was a
real interaction and here you can see in
this case that the interaction is now
downstream it's with the kinase domain
instead of with the upstream love
domains and here we found that stomatal
opening was in fact severely impaired a
couple of experiments here it's impaired
except when we can complement but that
of the 14th wild-type 1433 molecule back
in and we can restore normal still
mental function and in this case it was
even more highly specific in that this
is the only phenomenon the only
phototropic mediated phenomenon that we
can find that was impaired in the 1433
mutant highly specific to just that one
phosphorylation and association
well in 2007 bill eisinger joined the
lab he was a long time professor at
chateau-thierry university where he
didn't it's an undergraduate institution
and I was lucky enough that he wanted to
continue doing research so he joined the
lab he was interested in guard cells and
guard cells were affected by
photoactivatable soto tropin so our
interest were pretty much in common so
also I had a colleague Dave our heart
who had plenty of our rabid officers
that were carrying gfp tubulin so we
decided it would be fun to look at the
behavior of the microtubules and guard
cells as they closed door opened and
thanks today if we have very very good
confocal microscopy so this was the
initiation of this project and as you as
I mentioned this is this very large
literature on osmotic regulation of
stomatal aperture people like my class
Ali Osman jordan schroeder and a number
of others but only a limited amount of
information about the possible role of
the sudden cytoskeleton so as you know
schemes like this have been developing
and I find them understandable barely a
bit confusing so here's what bill first
saw these are guard cells now expressing
gfp tubulin and you see that the tubulin
is in hoops around the perimeter of the
guard cells and now this is for the
guard cell wide open if we treat with a
BA which induces closure a couple of
things happen first you see there are
lots and lots of these microtubules and
it turns out that the brighter ones are
probably bundled so I'll come back to
that in a minute but over time the
number of those bundles that you can
actually resolve decreases gradually
here's 30 minutes 40 minutes and also
there's been a loss in total
fluorescence and this is interesting
because the monomer of the
tubulin is just as fluorescent efe as is
polymer so there's a net loss of tubulin
rather significant loss of tubulin over
time and then if you correlate stomatal
aperture with the storm wheel aperture
with the number of these things that you
can count you see that there's a pretty
good relationship they're pretty clean
relationship and when they close the
number of aperture the aperture closes
and the time course for the loss in
structures that you can resolve goes
down simultaneously and then you can
take take these plants when they're
closed put them from the light the dark
they close the number of elements that
you can count goes down put him back in
the light they open and simultaneously
up come the number of those bundles that
you can see so why the decline well
maybe less growing into the microtubules
that's one things happen maybe you have
the same number of growing ends but
they're growing more slowly this could
account for some of the loss you could
have more rapid degradation at the minus
ends or some combination of those
processes so let's take a look at the
growing ends let's hope that this works
so we're going to be able to look at the
growing ends by looking at a different
label and this is n binding one gfp this
is an aunt of protein that's found at
the growing ends of microtubules and
let's hope
oops
yeah so you see now this is just
watching in time lapse and these are the
growing ends are those microtubules and
having this you can do to a thing it's
person the first place you can count the
number of them and seconds you can
measure the rate at which they're moving
and so we did that and this would tell
us maybe more specifically so garden
other well they're moving in a circular
fashion is difficult to tell whether
they're going under or over we think
that there are some going in both
directions but thats haven't really
studied that in any great detail but
here if we now look at the number as the
as the guard cells closed following a be
a treatment this is closing very nicely
but it doesn't change the number of
comets these little comets that you see
flying around so the number of growing
ends doesn't change just showing the
pavement cells along with the guard
cells and then if we look at the
velocity flow versus open there's no
difference either they're going just as
faster they're just as many of them so
we're left with the conclusion that
they're actually undergoing differential
degradation out there minus ends okay so
the question of the question then
becomes well do microtubules play a
major role in snow little opening and
closing but appearing when they open
their disappearing when them when they
close so do they play a function of
roller is this just simply something
passive that happens as a consequence of
opening and closing and there are ways
of testing that we can there are two
drugs arise alone that we can user I
think cosa seen does that do it arrival
and destabilizes microtubules and tax or
stabilizes them so we can try these
drugs and see what effect they have on
opening and closing
and in this experiment we're starting
with them initially in the dark we're
putting putting the leaves into the
light and either bisha or a rather
docsis you can see that the guard cells
open on the other hand if we have
treated with a rosalyn of these
structures don't reform as you can see
this is just sort of messy inside the
cell and they don't open on the other
hand if we treat the tax all they do
open and they open relatively normally
if we now do the reverse experiment
going from light to dark and normally
they would close in the dark with a
riesling of course they do close and
you've got the this same sort of mess
but in tax all they're stuck open so we
conclude therefore that the microtubule
changes that we observe on stomatal
opening and closing these changes are
required for normal some little function
one of the one of the questions you
might ask is well we've transformed
these plants and put different stuff
into the guard cells that was there
naturally so just maybe we've interfered
with interfered with transpiration so
this is just a classic water loss
experiment done with colleagues in the
ecological physiology group at carnegie
no matter wild type or any of these
transformants they're all behaving
perfectly normally so we don't need to
worry about that well then they'll
decided to try to get a little more
quantitative some of the early pictures
looked like that you could then draw a
line and scan across and get a little
profile of fluorescence hears from the
lower sale here from the top shelf and
then you put to some expel some
experiments such as this where when you
went into a VA with open guard cells you
notice that the high peaks gradually
decline in fact they're virtually all
gone after
whatever that is 40 minutes whereas in
the pavement cells there's no particular
change he then got more sophisticated or
i should say the equipment got more
sophisticated and now we have a better
better image and now you can take this
and rotate it so that you're now looking
at the ends of the microtubules of the
fluorescence from the gfp and then you
can draw a line here and do a scanner
you've got something it looks like this
and if you sort of squint at this you
could convince yourself that there are
some Peaks they're down in here some
Peaks that are around in here and some
Peaks that are here so maybe this isn't
going to be a uniform series from from
small to large maybe there'll be
discrete steps now but for this
particular one well you don't see that
very well but every once in a while
we've got something that looked like
this and rabbit one clearly was having a
single series of increments and we
interpret this isn't increasing in
bundling as the total number doesn't
decline all that much when they close
going down to here going down to here
but the number of high peaks drops down
that drops down step bars so we we
interpret that as a decreasing bundling
we're going from singles here and it
doubles two triples two quadruples and
so forth and this accounts for the
difference in the brightness of the
fluorescence that you see in those
various structures well now children and
as I mentioned doesn't lose its
fluorescence in the monomer so what are
the possibilities it could be that loss
of fluorescence is like is likely
proteolysis if that's the case then if
we treat with something that will be
given tory alisis just maybe we can
block the blocks terminal closing and
inhibit
fluorescence loss likewise cop cop one
is at e3 ligase and the cop one mutation
cop one is involved in all kinds of
things going on in plants but it was
known that the cop one mutation
prevented stovall closing so it might
also prevent the fluorescence loss so
here are a couple of experiments that we
could do so we're first thing is if we
inhibit proteolysis with mg132 you can
see that the i don't have my glasses on
but i assume that that's yeah that's the
stomach aperture all they do indeed they
do not close and if you look at
fluorescence the mg132 also very much
impairs the fluorescence loss that's
essentially reflects photo bleaching
that occurs under any circumstances and
again you can see that in DMSO we go
into a BA we lose the structures whereas
if we have mg132 present these guard
cells don't change particularly in the
appearance of the microtubules okay it
turns out that a lot more than just
proteolysis involved for enclosing
because you've been inhibit
transcription or translation here's
another protease inhibitor besides mg132
and again if you inhibit transcription
or translation you prevent the closing
reaction when they remain open in ABA
for after a 40-minute treatment
so there's a lot going on that at least
I hadn't expected on the other thing is
what about cop long well cop one as I
mentioned doesn't close incidentally if
you look at a couple and guard cells
notice that they're more nearly circular
than the wild-type guard cells and note
that in cop on a ba you can hammer them
you can't get them to close so there's
they are essentially stuck open and not
only are they stuck open but the
microtubules are not changed by the ABA
treatment so I guess that's consistent
with what we've seen before yeah this
shows the that's the stomach lurcher
unchanged in cap on and there is the
this is the fluorescence in cop one with
the controls here no different that's
just a bleaching whereas in the in the
wild-type top one protein you see the
fluorescence loss again plus a VA over
the same time course well if we disrupt
top 16 guard cell microtubules in the
Rogers can they get them to close and so
we tried that experiment and sure enough
if we treat them with arousal and they
do indeed close now this is now switch
dissing work by Rajesh Khanna who joined
the lab about three years ago on full
time and then a part-time basis and
they're still working with us on it and
you notice that if you treat now with a
rise alone the cop one guard cells now
they lose their microtubules but they
also close but now of course that could
be simply we made maybe you just killed
the cells and with the inhibitor so what
happens if we try to wash it out oh
here's just a quantitation the one to
look at is this one darker liked with a
riceland in kop one they close their so
again did we just kill the cells or in
fact can we recover them so if we do a
washout the microtubules structures
reappear and they open back up again so
we haven't just killed the cells and
again it's it's fairly good evidence
that these microtubule changes are
indeed essential for opening and closing
guard cells okay now the question then
becomes does the cuff one mutation in
any way affect electrophysiology of the
guard cells because after all they do
have to get driven by osmotic changes
calcium has to move in for opening at
and all these other things have to go
along and for this we started a
collaboration with Julian Schroeder's
lab at UCSD and jumbled John the league
as a postdoc there who did these
experiments and here is the
thing I showed you at the very start
that's ileum two important channels that
are worth mentioning there's this
potassium channel which is essential for
opening and then there's a slow an ion
channel whoops l is still an ion channel
which is right here which is required
for closing actually this is a very much
over simplified diagram I have another
more recent one but it's up for me was
just absolutely overwhelming so I chose
chose the simple one so required for
closing required for opening so let's
take a look at the behavior of those two
channels and so here's what happened
when he a gentleman looked at the
potassium channel got one in wild-type
is at the behavior that you get the
usual experiment voltage current plot
and you noticed it in cop one it's
absolutely normal there's no impact
whatsoever on top one on the potassium
channel but to our surprise when we look
then at the slack one the slow an ion
channel it was completely dead in
coffman in fact its behavior in the cop
one mutant was about the same as what
you would expect you this black one
mutant it was essentially non-functional
well that raises the question what's the
interaction between slap one and all
these microtubule studies and cop 1 and
what is the in fact what is the role of
these changes in my install mental
function structurally do they provide
some sort of structural contribution
that seems unlikely they're not all that
strong to be able to have a role in
changing the shape of the cell maybe
they're transporting vesicles to and
from the plasma membrane
remember that these cells are expanding
out they in in our experience in kop one
for example where there seems to be no
closure the pair of guard cells is
formed something it's almost circular
with a circular poor whereas in
wild-type the arrangement is a bit more
elliptical and the poor is smaller so
it's as if there's a balance between
opening processes and closing processes
but gives you some sort of interim
intermediate state of opening and when
in the presence of cop one we kill the
closing process then we're only seeing
the consequence of the opening processes
and they are after them they're at their
most distended and in fact very na in
almost circular confirmation as a result
so when you expand these cells and we
can argue about this later on we're
chatting about the shape and so forth it
looks it appears that there's a an
increase in the outer surface the size
of the area of the guard cells and this
means that one of two things either if
you're going to increase the surface
area at all easy you have to make it
thinner or you have to add material and
so it couldn't be that the role of these
microtubules is to transport vesicles
containing proteins and more membrane
material for a fusion with the plasma
membrane transport to an opening and
remove on closing well one of the ways
to look at that then would be to look at
what is the relationship between these
changes in slack ones if we could get a
/ one fluorescent label we could follow
it so we started to do that and these
are the our most recent experiments oh
this is slack one gfp and
it's the cop one cop one mutant so that
these guys are wide open and you can see
here that the slack one as you would
expect of a channel is pretty much
localized to the to the periphery of the
cells and not much in the interior also
if you now look at and again these are
very preliminary pictures you see that
the arrangement the first place is your
the meridian of the cells and it's more
there than it is on the upper and lower
surfaces the surface towards the air and
the surface towards the interior of the
leaf but also it's showing some kind of
structure the question is when they're
open like this is that structure
coincide in any way with the
microtubules because that would at least
be lead that things that the
microtubules could be involved in moving
stuff around well what does it look like
when they're closed what it looks like
if we now this isn't a cop 14 mutant but
if we now treat it with a risin and it
closed it remember we can close it so
that we could treat it with washing out
and get it to open again I think I've
shown in the next slow side does the
distribution change the stomatal opening
and closing and we're using top one is
our test system and you can see that the
change is really rather dramatic when
they're open the slack one gfp is mostly
peripheral at the plasma membrane
whereas when they're closed it now is
very much internalized internalized and
what appeared to be vesicles of some
sort the nature of which at the moment
we simply don't know as I say this these
are all very recent well so what the the
next step now and one which we're just
starting is to get plants that are
expressing both a fluorescent / one
another fluorescence
fluorescent tubulin but since what we
had was in both cases gfp that wasn't
going to work so we've had to work now
with different labels we finally have
just gotten some plants that are
expressing em sorry tubulin which is a
red floor and slack one GF p which is
the Greens lesser and peers here's last
week's picture this is the M cherry
tubular the slack one these are almost
closed and the picture here of course is
just sort of a mess but it's the very
first picture demonstrating that we do
in fact have that have double-labeled
fluorescent labeled planets and we're
going to be able to take a look and do
time course studies and watch and see
whether indeed the microtubules are
involved in moving moving vesicles
around containing slack one is who knows
what else that's our operating our
working hypothesis at this point and
with that I have to say that's clearly a
lot more to do so I'm looking forward to
a lot of neat pictures in the next six
months so with that are I mentioned tung
chung oh who did that earlier work
looking at post translational
modification of photoshopping on photo
excitation bill eisinger who did the
initial work on the initial work on
microtubules and then erogenous all of
this more recent stuff our collaboration
with Julian Schroeder that with thanks
special thanks to gunmen for making the
electrophysiological measurements and
we're half way up from Alvin but we
still have 600 meters to get to there
from here and that's a different
mountain by the way and we have a lot
more to do and people are going to be
busy I hope we're going to be busy for a
good while longer and support came from
both Carnegie and
from the National Science Foundation and
thank you very much for your attention
fluorescence or channel in the end the
final
it's largely in the other yeah we have a
have other pictures of that alone and
there's a sort of a band abounded it
around the ante tunnel it yeah i'm i'm
guessing we're guessing that it's in
fact in contact with this it's where
it's in contact with the surrounding
epidermal cells yeah the Comets canoe it
could be bringing stuff up that to
deliver I think we're in a position that
with not with my skills but with with
David Earhart's androgynous we might be
able to to probe that and find out
whether that's really what's going on
now the question is whether the the
hypothesized vesicles that are going
back and forth could have some impact on
the physical properties of the cell wall
I in no just my gut feeling is no I
don't mean to reject it out of hand but
I think it's unlikely because the
microtubules start out as being as the
guard cells develop of course they're
the microtubules are what determine
where the microfibrils are and that this
function that we're hypothesizing is a
later one and it's a function far
lecherous tell
the elastic modules
it's a reversible fossil so our ways of
testing that now there are ways of
testing the elastic module of a cell
wall and I've seen papers on that but so
is something we thought about but
haven't haven't done it would be very
interesting to test just that notion i
think the techniques are out there
whether we have the skill of a nuisance
properly or not for me to be seen gotta
get down there surfed money for that
like to go
that's right he gets he gets a really
elegant reorientation of feet of the
microtubules in the hypocotyl which is
clearly related to the change in the
growth pattern well we what we see
specifically is that in blue light the
microtubules increase in number and very
much increase in bundling about that's a
blue light response not other other
photoreceptors will modulate that
response but without without the photo
to opens you don't get any light
sensitivity at all for still metal
opening you see the takes about 40
minutes so there's plenty of time for a
lot else to happen I may have said
something misleading when I said the cop
one is involved in the degradation of
the microtubules because it could be
involved in the degradation is something
else that then place it could be much
more complicated than that oh no it's a
purely correlation and that is that the
fluorescence decline parallels the
parallels the time course for closing
and brother closely but I mean these are
happening it out on a timescale of many
many minutes so the time resolution
simply isn't good enough to say more
than at this point it looks as if
they're closely correlated better time
resolution might show the fest not a
servant case but that's a good question
and it caught me up because I tend to be
much too confident when I talk about cop
on and proteolysis and microtubules does
not have to be that's the primary event
could be interact
so have you shown for your carnation all
the of the microtubules and handbook
triggers to call you reckon nation was
the second synthetic pathway that
triggers for you I don't know about that
for for the microtubules I know that
there are these e liquid nation studies
in a product open itself but no I can't
I can't address that that's a
prerequisite for degradation yeah yeah
but we had to look at we simply haven't
looked at that
well well what's what's the length of
the guard cell 200 microns so they could
be those meant that there could be 100
the width of the cell micron or so but
no they vary a lot the bundles are going
to be bigger than that they singles in
our experiments the resolution wasn't
good enough to see singles and that's
why we thought we were actually losing
the number of a large number of the
structures proximately a small number
but he just were going from multiples to
the singles this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu